hydra is a framework that is developed
by facebook research um it is uh used to
configure
elegant application or elegantly
configured applications and it's really
growing in popularity especially among
machine learning researchers because it
helps you configure design and configure
projects like machine learning
experiments
hydrazine is then a open source library
that we have been developing at mit
lincoln laboratory
which helps add the zen of python to
using hydra we provide some really
convenient python centric functions
for creating configurations for working
with hydra and add some really rich new
features on top of the baseline hydra
framework
so what do hydra and hydrazine actually
do
first of all they standardize the
process of designing your project
and when i say project i mean both your
rapid prototypes the kind of work that
you're only going to deal with for a
couple days or a couple weeks
and also your mature projects things
that you're going to release publicly or
deploy
um
you can uh this standardized the process
for both form factors
and what exactly are we standardizing
what i mean is this helps to standardize
the process of making your code
configurable
we want to make sure that each of our
projects are configurable from a single
interface
such that i can configure deeply nested
parameters within my program so if i'm
doing like a machine learning project i
might have some algorithm that has
within it some machine learning model
that has within it some layer and some
parameter that i want to configure i
want to make sure that we can tunnel
down and configure that specific
parameter from the interface
and i also want us to be able to
identify entire components of our
program that we want to
make configurable and swappable
so maybe i'm dealing with data set a and
i want to swap it out for data set b
where i'm working with some baseline
algorithm but now i'm working on some uh
enhanced improved algorithm that i want
to be able to swap out conveniently
we're going to have a configurable
interface that allows us to uh
to swap those things out wholesale
hydra also helps us standardize the
process of making all of our work
reproducible
it will leave behind for us a breadcrumb
trail in the form of a serialized yaml
file of how we configured our code when
we ran it
and lastly it enables scalable workflows
so this means that i can configure and
launch multiple instances of my program
either locally in serial or in parallel
or even across multiple nodes on a
computing cluster like on aws or azure
hydro provides really powerful launchers
and sweepers for making short work of
this
okay so enough saying let's do let's
actually make something we're going to
create some toy code it's going to be
called
gamelibrary.py
we'll use hydrozen to design a
configurable interface for this library
and then we'll define a task function
that uses the library's code
once we have all of these things we'll
be able to configure and launch our
program
so we'll we'll do that
and then we'll see that it's actually
really easy to go back and add a command
line interface to this program as well
um
as i mentioned before hydra really helps
with reproducibility so we'll go and
follow that breadcrumb trail along and
see we really can reproduce our results
exactly from this program that we
created
um
and then we will go and identify some of
those con some of those groups that we
want to make wholesale
configurable and swappable
all right um so let's go ahead and make
some of that toy code
this is the complete content of
gamelibrary.py
it consists of two things a character
class um the character class just has a
name a skill level and an optional
inventory and then that like that
wrapper method there just makes sure
that for this uh presentation when we
print out our character instance it just
prints out nicely it displays the name
level and inventory so that's the only
reason why that is there
and then we have a simple inventory
function that takes in an amount of gold
a weapon or or item and a costume and it
just returns a dictionary with those
things
and i'll note i have type annotations or
type hints here some of you may or may
not be familiar with these
i'm using these here for documentation
purposes and i want to emphasize that
tie pins are not required to use
hydrazine you never have to have these
in your code in order to use hydrazine
but if you do have them we can provide
runtime type checking uh if you have
those hints
okay so to make sure that we're on the
same page let's import character and
inventory from our game library and just
use them real quick
so we'll take the inventory function and
we'll make some stuff that stuff
consists of 12 gold a stick and a red
cape and then we're going to make a
character the character's name is bowser
is level one and we gave bowser that
stuff
okay
great
so
we have some library code some toy
problem
and now what we want to do is create a
design a configurable interface so that
we can configure any aspect of character
and notice that the interface to
character is hierarchical in nature at
the top level we have name and level and
then the inventory
itself has configurable components so we
want our configurable interface to
reflect the hierarchical interface of
character
all right
so
in this code we are using hydrazine to
generate those configurable interfaces
the real start of the show here is
hydrazine's builds function
what you do is pass builds one of your
library's classes or functions and it
will automatically generate a
configurable interface for that object
so at the top here we have builds
inventory returns inventory conf that's
a configurable interface for inventory
and then car conf is a configurable
interface to character but something
really important to notice here is that
you can nest these configs so i created
a specific inventory loadout starter
gear 10 gold the stick and a tunic and i
included that as part of the character
configuration
so now any default character will start
off with that inventory but the real key
here is that you can compose or that you
can nest configurations and that allows
us to have that hierarchical interface
that i was describing before that we
desired
and then the top level config for our
program is really trivial we use
hydrazan's make config function and this
just says we have one field named player
and that player is described by that
character configuration
[Music]
all right well so we have a configurable
interface
now we want to define a task function
that actually
uses that configuration
so
the test function takes in
our uh config
and we call hydra's instantiate function
now this will actually recurse through
our configuration and make everything
that's the reason why that function in
hydrogen was called builds it describes
how to build an inventory it describes
how to build a character instantiate
goes through and actually builds those
things so it
instantiates that inventory according to
the config and then uses that to end the
name and the level to instantiate the
character class
so object obj dot player is just that
specific instance of the character class
what that name with whatever name level
and inventory we want that's all it is
um and then beyond this we can use this
character instance as we see fit here we
print it out we write a log file we
could call other python functions we
could launch an executable this um this
task function ultimately does anything
we want it just needs to take in that
configurable interface and do something
with it
okay that's all we have to do to have a
program that can be configured and run
using hydra and hydrazine
let's let's do it let's launch three
different instances of our program
so we pass hydrazine's launch function
our top level config our task function
and here we say okay our player's name
is frodo
so it's frodo has the default level and
an inventory
now we
launch a programming say that the
player's name is frodo has a level two
default inventory
and here we configure the same thing but
we also configure specifically the robe
within the inventory of this character
and this is where the a lot of the magic
is happening notice that we're able to
elegantly configure a nested field
within the character instance
player.inventory.com equals robe
this is indicative of how we can
configure anything in our program we can
access deeply nested parameters in this
intuitive dot name syntax to access and
set that parameter's value
so this starts to get at the
configurability that it gets
standardized by using hydra and
hydrazine
so
to rewind a bit how does hydra and
hydrazine standardize our project design
process
well it tells us that we need to do two
things design a configurable interface
to our program
and then
define a task function that actually
gets configured by that interface and
then runs whatever code we want to run
now what does it look like to actually
add a command line interface to this
program that launch function that i
showed before was a python function so
we can already configure and launch our
code from within python how do we do the
same from a command line interface
hydra makes short work of this um you
take your config and you register it
with hydra's config store you give it
the name of the config and where to find
it
take the task function
um decorate the task function with hydra
dot name and tell it what the top level
function uh config is and then at the
bottom there that just says hey if we
run this script make sure to execute the
task function
that's all it takes to add a command
line interface to our program it's
really simple basically no boilerplate
code
so
now we can go ahead and run our program
configure it from the command line
interface so this is exactly what we did
before with launch but now from the
command line
so
hopefully you're starting to be
convinced that hydra and hydro zen
really do help you write a configurable
program and it helps to standardize that
but how does this help with
reproducibility
well every time we run our program hydra
will serialize for us a comp complete a
yellow file that serves as a complete
description of how we configured that
specific instance of our code
so let's read through this together
we'll read from the bottom to top so
what this says is that the robe stick
intent gold is what configured the
gamelibrary.inventory function
and then that's the inventory within
this config
then that inventory level two and frodo
is what configures a specific instance
of gamelibrary.character
and that is what the player is in our
program
right so this is a complete description
of how we just ran the code
well given that it's a complete
description we can actually use this to
re-run our program in the exact same
fashion as before
so
hydro by default will save the results
of our program in a time stamp directory
which can be configured
we can instead of by hand saying the
player's name is frodo level 2 etc we
can just give it the config.yaml file
that it saved from our last run
and get identical results so you could
imagine if you're running some
um computer simulation doing some data
analysis or running an experiment and
you have some results from four months
ago and you're trying to remember like
how did i get that again you just
consult the config.yaml file and it is a
complete detailed description of exactly
how you ran that program and if you need
to reproduce those results you can just
feed that back to your programs
interface
okay so um
now let's go back to our code and see
that we can make entire groups of our
program configurable and swappable
here i'm going to make specific
inventory loadouts so starter gear
advanced gear and then my absolute
favorite hard load gear in which you
have zero gold your weapon is your inner
thoughts and you're wearing rags which
is like gonna be a tough time when
you're playing this game but
we create these um specific inventories
and then we register them in hydra's
config store under the group player
slash inventory and then we give each
each one an appropriate name starter
advanced hard mode
and then we can just refer to these by
name from our program's interface
similarly we can create entire player
configurations let's say brenda and
rakesh both really like our game and
they have saved character profiles
brenda is level 47 she wears a cape has
a flute and has 52 gold
similarly we can register these under
the group player so we have a base
character brenda's character profile and
rakesh character profile that we can all
refer to by name now
what does it look like to use this well
before i can uh you know here we have uh
player name ivy now we've given ivy the
hard mode inventory layout or loadout
with this simple uh player inventory
equals hard mode
we can load brenda's character profile
using player equals brenda really
intuitive nice
or we could load brenda's player profile
and this time give her armor instead of
a cape
so reflecting back on the kind of code
that you might be writing you might have
a configuration for data set a and data
set b and data set c you can just swap
those out by name from the command line
interface or from the launch interface
you might have a baseline model from a
research paper that you read and then
your version of your model you can refer
to you can make pre-built configurations
for describing those models and then
swap them out by name in your
experiments
so what do hydra and hydrazine actually
do
i hope i'm convincing you that they
standardize the process of designing
your project make a configurable
interface
define a task function that gets
configured by that interface and runs
your program
um
hopefully you're somewhat convinced that
this is really um
doable for rapid prototyping it takes
almost no boilerplate at all to
incorporate this into your code and also
hydra is a well-loved framework and
hydrazine is well tested these are good
to use for mature projects as well
and i'd like to point out that if you
and your colleagues are all using this a
benefit of that is you know how to
reproduce each other's results you know
to look for each other's config.yaml
files to understand how you ran each
other how uh one person ran their code
and you understand the paradigm of the
configurable interface and the task
function so this really helps uh prevent
people from having to reinvent the wheel
for configurable and reproducible
projects
and then lastly we haven't really gotten
to the scalability aspect yet we but we
will see that come into play um in the
next example but rest assured hydra
provides these really powerful launchers
that allows us to take the kind of
program that we just saw and run
multiple versions of it
um using different launchers include
including ray and slurm and different
things like that
okay this is pi data enough of this game
library talk let's do a pi data example
we are going to use one of my favorite
libraries pi torch lightning and hydro
zen to run some boilerplate free machine
learning experiments
and it wouldn't be a talk without a
neural network we are going to train the
world's simplest neural network a single
layer neural network that is just meant
to fit the cosine function between
negative 2 pi and 2 pi so this is just
going to take in a single number pass it
through the neural network and we hope
that the neural network returns cosine
of that number that's the ideal
we're actually going to train multiple
versions of this neural network using
different numbers of neurons in the
layers and different batch sizes the
amount of data that we pass during the
optimization or training process
so this looks like a lot of code
compared to what i've been showing you
but in the world of machine learning
this is nothing and there's nary a for
before loop in sight so it's also like a
christmas miracle even though it's not
christmas yet
um
at the top we have our single layer
neural network
and then a pi torch lightning module
that just describes how to run our model
how to create our optimizer for our
model what it looks like to update our
model from step to step
and how to load our data
so the lighting module takes care of all
of that
and then on the right we're using
hydrazine to make config configurable
interfaces for all of those things and
for all of you hydro users out there
this is where you get to see a little
bit of the hydro zen specific magic
here we're actually creating partial
configs like the atom optimizer we don't
have access to the model weights at
config time so we actually want to only
partially configure atom not fully
that's just an aside
so here we're creating a configurable
interface for our optimizer
our data loader
our neural network
the lightning module
our trainer how long do we train this
for do we use any gpus and then this is
the top level config for our experiment
it consists of a configurable interface
for an optimizer data loader lightning
module trainer and then also we provide
a configurable seed which we'll use to
seed all of our random number generators
our task function is really
straightforward
um
seed all of our random number generators
use hydra's instantiate to actually
instantiate our neural network our
lightning module optimizer data loader
create the lightning module itself
fit our neural network this is the
actual this is the single line that it
takes to train the neural network on the
data
evaluate the fully trained neural
network on the data and then return the
return the trained model along with the
final fit
all right um
that's all it took uh let's appreciate
all of the code on the left is all of
the machine learning baseline
the code on the right is making our
configurable interface with hydrazine
and then this is the code that actually
uh trains and evaluates our model
so now we'll use hydrazine's launch to
launch four instances of this
how do we launch four instances of this
by using the multi-run option we specify
that we're gonna run two different batch
sizes and two different number of
neurons in the layers
and hydra's hydro will run all four
combinations of those and it will
automatically separate out and organize
the results independently of each other
of those four experiments
so with this single line we're actually
training four separate neural networks
and these are the fits for the neural
networks um if you're curious uh the
layer 100 neuron layer with batch size
of 20 did the best but obviously we can
do better than this this is just fitting
cosine on a very small domain but this
is just to show um uh example of this in
the world of machine learning so this
gets at some of the scalability that i
was mentioning you could also provide a
launcher and train these models in
parallel
so
reproducibility this is the
config.yml for one of the experiment
runs that we did in training this model
notice there are parameters here that we
didn't even explicitly set like this
documents the beta parameters in our
optimizer the epsilon that we used this
is this
it even includes the uh seed that we use
for a random number generator so this
completely details how we ran one of our
ex one of our four experiments
okay uh with the time that i have
remaining some of hydro zen's bells and
whistles we won't be able to get up to
all of these
first i mentioned you don't have to have
type annotations but if you do have type
annotations we can inject runtime type
checking in all of your interfaces in
this example we have a really fancy type
hint positive int that says not only
should age be an int it should be
non-negative
we're going to use a wrapper called
validates with bear type and that will
change the behavior of builds so builds
will add an additional step to the
instantiation process
for all of our configs that adds runtime
type checking based on their interfaces
so this uses the bear type type checking
library which i'm a big fan of um
so
what does this look like in stan sheet
this config with age of the into 12 no
problem
pass it the word 12 as a string bear
type will roar it will raise an error
saying hey this value does not match the
type annotation
and you pass it a negative integer
that's also no good because our type
hint says positive integers so you can
now type check the configurable
interface to your very precious
experiment
we provide support for bear type and
pydantic so all of you folks out there
who like pedantic and have wanted to use
it with hydra we've built the bridge now
and this is actually a completely
general feature that i'm showing this is
not specific to type checking this is a
functionality injection system via zen
wrappers so you can provide whatever
wrappers you want and they'll compose
during the instantiation process so you
can easy easily add things like schema
validation and affect the actual
functional behavior
i'm going to speed ahead a little bit
but i'll tell you that when you use
builds it will also validate itself upon
construction so if you want to make sure
that your configs are valid um just
make the configs with builds and it will
raise errors if you misspelled parameter
names you can even just import these in
your test suite and then in your test
suite it will revalidate your configs
really cool
and there are more bells and whistles of
hydrazine but not enough time
we have nice box that we just rewrote we
have tutorials for folks who are
completely new to hydra and hydro zen
we'll step you through all of the things
that we just discussed here step by step
and hydra and hydro zen are both on
github
please consider giving us some stars it
really helps with discoverability hydra
is already like through the roof popular
but hypezen is a very new project so if
you think this is cool it helps
get new users to find a project and then
please follow me at rsocal at both
github and
twitter
shout outs
hydra for laying the foundation for
absolutely all of this the
hypothesis testing library which we use
to rigorously test all of hydrazine pi
torch lightning and bear type the bare
metal pipe checker
thanks everyone thanks so much ryan for
this presentation today and for all your
contributions at pi data global